uh okay so you were obviously rapping
for a while
um
when did you feel like you started to
catch some traction where you could be
like oh I this might work out for me
um it was just always little things that
happened
um I back in like 2015 I got my first
placement on this um album Rico Love's
album actually yes
um on this song called bad attitude
featuring me him and rayquan wow yeah so
that was like my first album placement
then from there I ended up like signing
and getting a deal but it was like
um it was through somebody I don't want
to mention [ __ ] them but yeah but
essentially
um they left they were the VP at a big
record label and ended up leaving and
then my stuff was kind of like in limbo
for a year so I was just sitting like
not doing [ __ ] that happens a lot it's
like the people that sign you they get a
better job or they get fired and then
there's all these new people that come
in and they're like well we didn't sign
her they don't they don't believe in you
the same way the people who signed you
believed in you right right and if you
sign through somebody else like it don't
really make a difference because it
ain't [ __ ] that they can do they don't
really have the ties so so you kind of
went through like uh the full music
uh industry experience yeah like he was
trying to like stop bags he was trying
to stop people from [ __ ] with me like
it was crazy really is this like a
famous person I mean he's well known
he's not like an industry guy
he industry but like behind the scenes
industry but like what was the big label
it was a big one it was it was one of
the the top five ones yeah for the Def
Jam
what
but yeah but [ __ ] him because at the end
of that jam no I wasn't there
it was a deaf jail okay it wasn't
definitely
but like you know so it was Atlantic
no
so it was Colombia you know what
anyway but like I actually seen it when
I was doing the red carpet at the BET
Awards because I had to decipher him
right and you know it just was a good
feeling it was just like damn you tried
to stop and look at me now that's pretty
crazy that someone would go out of their
way to try to
stop money from like a somebody who's
just trying to make ends meet I mean it
happens more often than not especially
the females you think so for sure yeah
I've gotten deals stopped because I
didn't want to [ __ ] with Executives I've
gotten deals stopped because obviously
you know a person wasn't doing anything
and they just wanted me to just sit and
wait like it's crazy